et le virus toucherait beaucoup plus les
quartiers défavorisés ici une étude
publiée par l'observatoire régional de
santé d'île de france révèle une
surmortalité dans la région depuis le
début de l'épidémie particulièrement
concerné la seine saint denis
département le plus pauvre de la région
parisienne entre le 1er mars et le 10
avril il a enregistré une hausse de plus
de 118 % du nombre de décès un chiffre
révélateur de la situation des banlieues
françaises pour majin mais ça aide
élu municipal de saint denis la seine
saint denis par avec beaucoup de
handicaps
on a un système hospitalier qui est
moins moins efficients qu'ailleurs on a
trois fois au moins de lits de
réanimation qu'à paris on a une
population qui en bonne partie ne peut
pas télétravail et parce que ce sont des
gens qui sont dans les secteurs que l'on
dit est essentielle au plus près
d'ailleurs du public et donc c'est une
population qui est surexposé aux virus
quotidiennement depuis des semaines
et puis donc c'est une population qui
vit aussi un confinement très compliqué
en termes de logement parce que ce sont
des logements qui sont pour une partie
insalubre et donc effectivement la
surmortalité de plus de 100% qu'on a
noté par rapport à l'an dernier à la
même heure au même jour est quelque
chose qui est juste un révélateur de la
situation à seine-saint-denis de la
précarité qui existent tout au long de
l'année et de ce qu'on dénonce donc en
fait la seule vraie question qui vont se
poser c'est est ce que tout ça est le
fruit du hasard
non tout ça c'est le fruit de politiques
menées depuis de trop longues années
dans les quartiers populaires ça fait
des années que les services publics ont
déserté les quartiers populaires ça fait
des années que l'état des investis dans
les quartiers populaires ces chiffres la
mora il ne me surprennent pas il
confirme juste ce qu'on dénonce à
longueur d'année et la responsabilité
elle incombe à tous les gouvernements
qui se sont succédé depuis 30 ans